de férfiaknál is ugyanígy jellemző ez
amikor azt mondjuk hogy a tinkori
ruháiban mert méretben még mindig jók és
akkor miért cseréljem le hát azért mert
megváltozott az élethelyzeted mert egy
egészen más szerepkörnek kell neked
megfelelni mától vagy tegnaptól vagy öt
évvel ezelőtttől és te nem vetted fel
ezt az ívat ha férj lettél ha apa lettél
ha olyan irodai környezetben dolgozol
ahol dresskó van ha tárgyalni jársz ha
ügyfelekhez jársz ha klienseid vannak
akkor ugye két más od perc alatt ennyi
eldönteni hogy te oké közelebb jöhetsz
vagy nem és hogyha azt mondják hogy nem
jöhetsz közelebb az első benyomás után
akkor nagyon sok idő és energia amíg
leépíted ezt a fals első benyomást és
miért pazarolni az időt és az energiát
olyasmire ahol ott lehetne ezeket sokkal
kreatívabban használni